so und jetzt die gina putsches hält
mache ich schon immer in dem ich push up
bh tragen
tina du hast mir den rest gegeben etwas
glück war ein video und zwar kam ja
letztens mein ross 11 bzw
mein neuer song mein neues musikvideo
kam online und ist eigentlich sogar
ziemlich gut bei euch angekommen es gibt
natürlich mal wieder ein paar so denken
und party so denken und ich habe
wirklich sehr lange zeit damit verbracht
die kommentare unter dem video zu
analysieren und ich habe einfach mal für
dieses video heute die ja ich hab halt
einfach mal die besten die beliebtesten
die aussagekräftigsten kommentare
rausgesucht die seine voll auf den punkt
bringen und solche videos seid ja von
mir gewohnt ich meine wenn von mir ein
video nicht gut ankommt da muss ich dazu
aufstellung nehmen und sagen so jo ihr
könnt doch nicht so viele displays
lassen und sonst was
deswegen gibt's heute das video ist auf
jedem video über 100000 kriegs noch bei
dem vierfachen abos ist das eigentlich
ein
du bist du denkst du bist ich finde
sowas lächerliches auch nicht so sein
ding
mein gott so bett sorry i like und du
bekommst eine million euro und für immer
glück top kommentar hakan solche
kommentare finde ich geil
weißt du bescheid ja ja das sind dann
halt auch mal zur kommentare die mich
dazu anregen nachzudenken ob das
wirklich sinn macht was ich mache ob
wirklich voll und ganz dahinter stehe
ob ich vielleicht doch nicht eingreifen
sollte mit allen nicht leicht was leute
wir kommen jetzt zu wirklich den
heftigsten kommentaren unter dem video
und die muss ich einfach mal beantworten
und wie fast von an mit dem ersten
kommentar und er kommt vom lieben
ich bin's real kann es nicht mal
englisch so einen scheiß trend typ in
dem video gab es zwei englische wörter
glaube ich einmal hombruch und vorne weg
und ich habe ich nicht gesund echt ich
bin's release auch schon fehler drin das
heißt ich bin wohl der nächste kommentar
kommt von darlehen platzt und sie oder
er schreibt wie einfach jeder youtuber
denkt er keinen rappen singh auf jeden
fall wann ich meine es war ja keine rost
yourself challenge sondern wirklich ein
total ernst gemeinter song in dem ich
meine singh künste beweisen wollte alex
wie du bist dein wannabe ey du kannst
von gut 7 ha jung ich weiß irgendwie
sehe ich in letzter zeit verläuft direkt
der nächste kommentar der cool aus der
schule schreibt wer vielleicht auch was
alex wieder beste youtube kanal ist
findet das aber jetzt kommt der haken
bei 30 likes und zehn neue abos kommt
mein alex li prank degas wat fürn
training
ich kenne ich nicht mal hast du mich
irgendwie bist du nachts hier
eingebrochen und hast mich gekränkt die
wirklich immer so leichtgläubig seien
leute das kann doch nicht ernsthaft so
ein scheiß hat 100 likes die liebe coco
schreibt nein alex ich dachte du rennst
den trends nicht hinterher
aber da habe ich wohl falsch gedacht und
wieso nimmst du homo oder [ __ ] als
beleidigung erstmal hatix ob ich mein
hast du nicht richtig zugehört thema
kurzen ausschnitt das
daher ist eine vorzeige [ __ ]
grenzt dem trend hinterher bis eine
vorzeige [ __ ]
aber kommen wir auch schon sofort zum
nicht also habe ich doch selber gesagt
dass ich dem trend hinterher in aber du
hast ja eine andere frage gestellt und
zwar warum nämlich homo und [ __ ]
als beleidigung hey das ist keine
beleidigung hast du nicht den letzten
youtube tief mitbekommen so sachen wie
[ __ ] [ __ ] oder sonst was das
ist nur ein stilmittel ich mein es liegt
doch auf der hand dass du einfach in
deiner neuen deutsch klausur [ __ ]
schreiben kannst das ist nur ein
stilmittel das wird jeder ganz normale
deutschlehrer der nicht völlig bekloppt
ist auch so anerkennen also etwa das war
geklärt so lautet der kommentar der
jetzt kommt den hab ich wirklich so oft
gelesen und zwar hier ist das video ja
official 4k videos ganz einfach weil das
videoformat oder die auflösung 4 k s das
nennt man so es gibt hd 720 oder 1080 hd
bla bla bla und es gibt 4 k
denn wirklich eine richtig große
qualität da ist okay ihr habt recht das
video war eigentlich in 4k aufgenommen
aber nur in full-hd gerendert somit habe
ich einfach nur viel kein titel
geschrieben umher klicks zu kriegen
auf jeden fall gab es ein paar
schlauberger von euch die meinten warum
schreibt er 4 k anstatt 400k leute
erstens also wahrscheinlich wegen 400
cabo special
das sollte keine abos beispiel sein dass
sollte die rost yourself challenge sein
etwas anders dargestellt aber also meine
freundin die auflösung war 4k nicht 400k
ich glaube es gibt auch noch gar nicht
wird noch ein paar jährchen dauern bis
man in 400k aufnehmen kann aber damit
hätten wir auf diesen kommentar geklärt
so und jetzt die gene q cells mache ich
schon immer in dem ich push up bh tragen
tina du hast mir euch in den rest
gegeben was willst du dazu noch sagen
ach komm ein halber noch möchtegern
rapper auf jeden fall ich würde mal
sagen einfach alex wie alex v oder
justin bieber mit seinen schlecht
moniert nahe übersehe ich dich liebe
bis auf youtube schon seit 2013 doch ist
immer noch scheiße sagt mir wann wir uns
einen ist auf jeden fall so was von
möchtegern weil ich mich auch so gut
dastehe bist du behindert behindert war
nur ein stilmittel übrigens leute das
war's mit diesem video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen checkt auf jeden fall noch
mal mein song ab und lasst mal einen
richtig negativen kommentar da weil ich
das alles komplett ernst meine einfach
irgendwo
oder in der video schreibung verlinkt
ansonsten sehen wir uns morgen eventuell
wieder ich weiß es noch nicht ganz sechs
matches ab da bin ich jetzt wieder voll
aktiv alex mit doppelpunkt re also ach
scheiß egal ist ihr kurz ein gemeinsames
morgen habe ich dann gleich haut rein
instagram machtvoll die werbung